das ist ein haus wir haben es für unser
easy languages training gemietet
[Musik]
das sind und tony moore und tony
stehen vor dem haus im moment wohnen wir
in diesem haus das haus liegt auf dem
land gerade wollte ich euch die
wunderschöne natur zeigen
doch dann bin ich in ein loch gefallen
jetzt muss ich mir andere klamotten
anziehen
bis gleich
ich bin zurück mit neuer kleidung
das sind agha und justina von easy
polish und das ist anja von easy raschen
wir gehen zusammen in das haus jetzt
sieben die wir im haus das ist unser
konferenzraum sophie und die metris
arbeiten im konferenzraum sowie was
machst du gerade
ich mache ein logo für easy den ich sehr
gut
dimitris was machst du gerade
ich will arbeiten aber das internet
funktioniert nicht
das ist sehr schade
das ist das esszimmer hier haben
menschen kuchen gegessen und nicht
aufgeräumt
das ist unsere küche hier machen wir
frühstück mittagessen und abendessen
die metris spült das dreckige geschirr
ab endlich was macht toni an der ecke er
guckt verwirrt die metris hat schon eine
tasse abgespült dimitris das machst du
sehr gut
mohammed hat eingekauft
er legt die einkäufer auf der
arbeitsplatte ab danke mohammed bitte
das ist der herd
hier kochen wir heute morgen haben wir
ja gekocht
jetzt zeigen wir euch die toilette da
sitzt schon jemand juan sitzt auf der
toilette und liest die nachrichten
dieses haus hat zwei stockwerke jetzt
gehen wir in den zweiten stock im
zweiten stock sind unsere schlafzimmer
jetzt sind wir in einem schlafzimmer ich
frage mich wer da unter der decke liegt
da liegt justina unter dem molli
christina unter der decke jetzt zeigen
wir euch hier ist inas badezimmer wo
justyna ist gerade unter der dusche
wollt ihr noch mehr präpositionen mit
justyna sehen
dann klickt hier jetzt sitzen wir im
garten
dieses haus hat einen sehr großen garten
in berlin haben wir keinen garten in
berlin leben wir an einer hauptstraße an
einer sehr lauten hauptstraße
das war unser video über unser haus in
diesem haus machen wir gerade unser
training für easy languages produzenten
in diesem video habt ihr einige
produzenten gesehen zum beispiel toni
von easyfairs juan von easy spanish oder
justina von easy polish ihr solltet
unbedingt den esel englisches kanal
auschecken und euch dort die videos von
unseren produzenten angucken hier und
hier könnt ihr neue videos sehen
danke fürs zuschauen und bis bald
[Musik]